it probably was however it plays out to
sean watson's last contract in houston
you know miles yesterday during the show
when the word broke that tyrod taylor
had agreed to terms with the texans my
first thought was the texans finally
have reached acceptance they've gotten
through anger denial bargaining and
depressions and they accept that they
have a problem
whether they're accepting that they have
to trade
deshaun watson or
they're accepting that they need a
viable quarterback on the roster if
watson sits out that's still not clear
but you and i both saw the tweet today
from john mclean when he says
that he believes
that desean watson will be traded and
this is the guy who on january 7 said
he's got a better chance of being the
next coach of the texans
than
than desean watson being traded that was
january 7. we're just two months and
change past that and he's come not full
circle he's done the 180.
and uh
i i think that means deshaun watson's
getting traded and that the signing of
tyrod taylor isn't to be insurance
against desean watson sitting out it's
to be their quarterback
until they bench him for whoever they
draft in round one
like what happened to tyrod taylor with
the browns and with the chargers
yeah or or it could just be that he's
gonna be the back up to two attacker by
law if they end up shipping deshaun
watson to miami and then maybe he could
be the relief pitcher since tuatacolo
needed one of those last year so i i
think that when you see john mclean say
something and the way he's been
following the story obviously he's
evolved on what he thinks of this and i
think as time has gone on okay you got
to think about what was going on back
then on that date in january the the
texans didn't have a head coach yet i
don't think we knew
quite the full extent of desean watson's
frustrations we hadn't gotten to the
point where the texans didn't really
interview eric the enemy until
after it came out that desean watson was
upset that they hadn't we didn't get to
the point where you know they hadn't
really talked seriously with robert
sally even though deshaun watson had
said hey this is a guy that i think we
might want to be interested in so i
think from there to now there's been a
lot of things that have happened and
there have been more things that have
come out about the houston texans
organization whether it's cal mcnair
whether it's jack easterby you know the
way they went about hiring casario
there's just a lot of things i think
that have happened in the last couple of
months that have really cemented deshaun
watson's feelings as to why he doesn't
want to play for the texans any longer
and i think that it would behoove the
texans and it would probably be in their
best interest to trade him sooner than
later because his value is never going
to be as high i think as it is right now
or maybe it might get a little bit
higher but at least by the time they're
drafting at the end of april i don't
know that it's going to be higher than
that mike
i think the thing that needs to happen
now and this is what needed to happen
back in january you find out the teams
to which desean watson would accept a
trade because he has a no trade clause
where do you want to go and even without
a no trade clause franchise quarterback
he's gotta want to go to where he's
being traded or that team shouldn't want
him just like the bears never made a
real offer for carson wentz because
wence didn't want to go to the bears so
with or without the no trade clause you
can't do this deal if the guy didn't
want to be there so deshawn where do you
want to go give us a fair list and then
you
you start the bidding peter king has
suggested a blind auction because he
think that's that's the way to get the
most out of david tepper the panthers
owner but however you do it you do it
and you do it before
the teams
to which watson would accept a trade
lock in
to their long-term quarterback answers
and right now i see the jets the
dolphins
and the panthers and the broncos and the
broncos because i think the broncos can
tread water with drew lock until the
ninth overall pick in the draft
and see how it plays out and i think the
draft round one that's when you want to
get it done by because if you're the
texans i assume you'd like to have
2021 draft capital not 2022. and there's
no reason to hold his contract until
after june 1 like with russell wilson
there's not some gigantic cap charge if
you trade him right now so
i i think it makes sense
because really who who's left if russell
wilson's not getting traded andy dalton
signed jameis winston signed ryan
fitzpatrick's sign you got marcus
mariota you got sam darn you got
mitchell trubisky i think at this point
you can start a process
that has a deadline
of the night the draft starts
that's when we're going to determine
where deshawn watson is going to go
i would also maybe put the 49ers on that
list just because i mean as you said
they probably want to upgrade from jimmy
garoppolo and they've got a pick that's
not too low at least for 2021 um in that
first round of the draft so if that's a
place where desean watson would want to
be i think at least with the way that
defense is constructed and the personnel
that's on that defense he would at least
have a pretty good chance to win and we
know how good kyle shanahan is at
scheming and they've just signed alex
mack they have trent williams back so
that offensive line is also built to
protect him and he was one of the most
sacked quarterbacks in the league in
2020 so i just think that there could be
some things with san francisco also that
would be appealing to deshaun watson and
so i i think any number of those teams
could make a call and say listen this is
what we think desean watson is worth you
know whether it's three first round
picks four however many it happens to be
and i think the dolphins obviously have
the most draft capital that they could
use and you know sending some of the
texans picks back to them but whatever
it is i just feel like the texans are
gonna have to capitalize on the
opportunity that they have which is to
trade him and then also to start
rebuilding their franchise because as
long i feel like as deshawn watson is
there it's just going to be a cloud over
whatever this franchise wants itself to
be
and until you remove that cloud
i just don't know how you get yourself
from out from under that mike
we've kicked around from time to time
over the past two months some trade
scenarios that
are highly unlikely but fun
to think about whether it's desean
watson straight up for the number one
overall pick in the draft which is the
trevor lawrence selection whether it's
desean watson for kyler murray maybe
straight up maybe the cardinals have to
throw a log or two on the pile to even
it out you could make the argument that
straight up would work if you're the
49ers
do you put nick bosa in a trade package
if the texans say the only way this is
getting done is if you give us nick bosa
yeah i'd do it i would do it because you
know what you got to score points to win
in this in this game and in this league
and you'd be sending nick bosa at least
to the totally opposite conference so
you probably see him once every four
years around there maybe once every
couple years based on the way the 17
game schedule would work out and or if
you have to see him you see him in the
super bowl i would do it point you got
to score you know defense may win the
championships but you got to score
points in order to get there so
yeah i would i would totally do it
then the challenge becomes evening out
the two sides of that scale you put boca
here you put watts in here it's probably
still
right so what do you put what else do
you have to throw on there is it is it
nick bosa and your first round pick for
deshawn watson i mean let's be realistic
quarterbacks are the ones making 40
million plus the high end for a pass
rusher was 27. you got shaq barrett the
premier pass rusher this year who
couldn't even get someone to offer more
than the 17 base that the buccaneers put
on the table it's going to take nick
bosa
and at least a one
to to balance it out especially because
the 49ers where are they 12 are they at
12 they're somewhere between 9 and 20.
and i i every time every time i look at
it i think i'm going to remember this
now and i inevitably forget but uh
well
with it is 12 thank you matt casey with
deshawn watson
and without nick bosa
it's still scary to think of what the
49ers can be and with russell wilson
still
in the nfc west with matthew stafford
coming to the nfc west eventually i
think the rams have some capped cleanup
to do before they take the jared goff
acceleration with kyler murray there and
you bring deshaun watson holy crap what
a division that would be
yeah that'd be really really fun so
selfishly i guess i want to see it in
part for that reason because all those
quarterbacks have to play each other
twice a year but i just feel like
especially if you're kyle shanahan and
you have the opportunity to get a
quarterback who's that good and is still
that young you know i think we all
expect the rams are going to be better
when they add in matthew stafford but
matthew stafford's already basically in
his mid 30s so you get a guy who's still
in his mid-20s and is that young and you
still think has room to grow
yeah i would trade nick bosa i would
probably add in a couple ones too just
because that
it seems to make sense to me
if that were to be the case where i can
get that particular guy
that to me is all in if i if i have to
trade nick bosa i'm gonna do it if i
have to add in a couple more ones i'm
gonna do it if it's gotta be another two
and a three probably would do that too
because that's how important i think the
qb position is
if i was setting the odds on this and
thank god i'm not or i'd lose my shirt
i'd probably put the dolphins at plus
250 then i'd put the broncos at plus 350
or plus 400 then i'd throw
the jets in there at plus
550 plus 600 and the 49ers maybe at that
same number those would be the four
teams that that i would make the
favorites for deshawn watson and
whatever the odds were of the texans
being the next team for which watson
takes a snap
i i it's you know it's plus 2 500 at
this point if not more um i think that
that we're getting closer and closer to
the point where
wherever it is it's not going to be
houston
yeah no doubt i think that clearly like
and like we just started off talking
about this with you know when john
mclean says something about the nfl in
houston that's when you know
that it really is something to pay
attention to because that guy is plugged
in as can be in houston uh you didn't
mention the panthers in that and i'm
sort of i did forget the panthers i
forgot the panthers i yeah i put them in
somewhere between
between the the uh
maybe right around the same spot as the
broncos because i'm not sure he wants to
go to carolina i've heard nothing to
suggest that he does i know carolina
wants him but i don't know that he wants
to go there
yeah and that's been the thing to me
with this whole carolina thing and we
hear all a lot about carolina's pursuit
of him but i just i really haven't seen
the reporting that he also is interested
in them and that's so important because
he has the no trade clause so until he's
like we get some sort of really credible
reporting that says yes deshaun watson
wants to go to the carolina panthers i
just don't quite know what to make of
that pursuit i mean even though he
played at clemson so that's an obvious
connection to the carolinas there and i
believe he grew up just a couple hours
away from charlotte and georgia so
that's another thing that you could say
yeah that might make sense for the
panthers but at the same time i just i
still haven't really seen something
where it's definitively yes desean
watson is interested in playing for matt
rule and the carolina panthers
sometimes you get a chance to go home
you don't want to go home that's just
the way it works and maybe that chapter
of his life is closed and he wants to
continue to move forward in a different
direction with a different team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports